>> So it's an interesting question will China
pull us out of the economic crisis and I assume
by "us" you mean the rest of the world.
Well, without China's participation in the
quarterly bond options of
the United States, interest rates would be
much higher, there would be
more illiquidity in our financial market,
so to a great extent China
has been a force of stability throughout the
financial crisis in
providing a buyer for our treasury bonds in
addition to other OECD
countries, Japan and Europe and G7, are major
buyers of US bonds but
China has also been a significant buyer.
Without that source of liquidity, we would
have been in a much worse
financial country size.
To the extent that China is -- still has a
huge trade surplus and the
United States still has a huge trade deficit,
this capital flow or
cycle capital of flows will continue where
capital surpluses, dollar
surpluses as a result of the trade surplus
building up in the Chinese
central banks, and commercial banks will continue
to be invested back
in dollar denominated assets as well as European
and commodity-based
assets in Africa and Latin America.
So China is a large buyer in the world market
of commodities, both soft
commodities as well as energy and metals and
that will continue to be
stimulus in those sectors as well as the financial
stimulus from the
purchase of bonds.
As far as the being a manufacturing center
China obviously has a lower
labor rate than all the G7 countries.
But there are other countries in southeast
Asia that have -- are
beginning to compete with China over the last
several years including
Vietnam, for example, has a very strong software
sector.
And that's clearly small compared to India's
software's sector and the
Chinese software sector is enormous.
They're one of the top five software producers
in the world.
Nusoft is one of the largest software out
sourcing firms in China.
They have major presence here in Dalian.
And they work with many Fortune 500 companies,
helping them save money
in their outsourcing and software development
and maintenance of
software.
So I think that to the extent that there is
a lot of economic activity
in China and the growth rate is between 6
and 8 percent depending on
the sector, there will be, continue to be
sector specific stimulus of
corresponding sectors in the world economy.
But I think it's important to rank these sectors
by order of magnitude
of stimulus, and recognize that China's both
an importer and an
exporter of capital, and an importer and exporter
of commodities and an
importer and exporter of technology.
For example, solar cells, here in Dalian,
solar EVC is being produced
for the world market at very competitive rates
here in Dalian.
So I think it's important when you ask such
a broad question, will
China pull us out of the economic crisis,
one has to define which
sector, over what timeframe, and what are
the competitive elements
within each sector where China does play a
role either as a buyer or as
a seller to collaborate, to produce increased
economic benefits for
counterparties.
And so I think this question is very general
and requires more
specificity and let's say corollary questions
in order to come up with
a more scientific answer that's more precise.
I know that some people have said, yes to
the question and some people
have said no.
Clearly, I think the answer is net yes that
there is a positive
economic stimulus coming from Asia in general,
because most of the
growth in the world is coming from Asia now.
Of course, Europe and the United States are
just coming out of
recessions and economic growth is negative
in certain sectors and
positive in other sectors.
There's still a lot of de-leveraging going
on in the United States
where there's been a very high savings rate
in China, and they did not
have the same degree of leverage that the
United States and Europe had
in their housing sectors and their commercial
real estate sectors and
in their banking sectors.
It was less -- there was not as much speculative
excess in China in
their financial markets.
So I think that when you survey the economic
landscape of China and
analyze the sectors that are providing economic
stimulus to the rest of
the world, it's important to look at the sectors
that have the
potential of pulling certain sectors out of
the economic crisis.
I don't see China becoming a major buyer of
US real estate in the near
future.
I don't see China exporting a lot of electric
cars to the United States
in the near future.
I don't see the R&B being devalued at a significant
rate in the near
future.
If it -- if the R&B were devalued that would
destabilize the United
States.
It would also destabilize China's portfolio
which is denominated in
dollars.
So the Chinese have a dilemma in that they
do not want the US dollar to
be destabilized.
They want to continue to buy dollar denominated
assets including
treasury bonds, and they want those asset
values to remain stable as
measured in the dollar R&B exchange rate.
So on balance I would say it's a wonderful
question because it provokes
a very important debate.
But one needs to disaggregate and deconstruct
this question in order to
have a higher degree of specificity about
what sectors are stimulated
by Chinese economic growth, and also look
the competitive matrix of
each sector globally and see what percentage
China contributes to
imports and exports in each sector.
And to that extent, good luck in that research.
A lot of that research has already been done
by thinktanks and
economists focusing on the US/China and US/European,
US/African,
US/Latin American economic bilateral relationship.
And I think that is the good starting point
so to look at large capital
close between China and the world and look
at sector-specific imports
and try to make some deductions.
So good luck in that research and again thank
you for tuning into this
Davos debate.